على قطاع النفط السوري الى الواجهه بعد
دخول الحرف في سوريا عامها الثاني عشر مع
استمرار السرعه الامريكيه الروسيه للسيطره
على امكانيات سوريا النفطيه ما سمح
للمسلحين المحليين واثرياء الحرب والخصوم
بالتعاون معا للاستحواذي على ما تبقى من
ثروات النفط وعائلتها انتاج النفط بلغ من
الحقول والمنشات الواقعه بشكل رئيسي في
شمال شرق سوريا حوالي 400 الف برميل يوميا
قبل بدء الصراع وبعد اندلاعه عام 2011
سيطرت قوى متناحره مختلفه مما في ذلك
فصائل من المعارضه وتنظيم داعش على جزء
كبير من هذه الثروه النفطيه فالعقبات
الغربيه المفروضه على قطاع النفس السوري
دفعت بشركات النفط الاجنبيه لمغادره
البلاد في الوقت الراهن تسيطر قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه وهي عباره عن ابتلاف المدعومه
من الولايات المتحده على ربع الاراضي
السوريه بما في ذلك من طاقه شرق الفرات
الغنيه بالنفط مما يعني ان قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه بدعم امريكي تسيطر الان على
90% من النفط واكثر من 50 بالمئه من حقول
الغاز الطبيعي في المقابل اعلن النظام
السوري ان خسائر قطاع النفط منذ بدايه
الازمه بلغت اكثر من 90 مليار دولار
[موسيقى]